NATHANIEL MANISTA: Welcome
to Google Developers Live.
I'm Nathaniel Manista of
Google's Open Source programs
office, and I'd like to
introduce Drew Rodman.
Drew is here to tell
us about his experience
with Google Summer of Code.
Drew, first tell
us about yourself.
DREW RODMAN: Hey Nathaniel,
thank you for having me.
So my name is Drew.
I'm currently a fourth
year university student,
and I first participated
in Google Summer of Code
during my second
year at university,
and I have had a phenomenal
experience thus far.
NATHANIEL MANISTA:
How did you learn
about Google Summer
of Code, and then
what made you decide
that it was the right way
to spend your summer?
DREW RODMAN: So I
first heard about it
through my college's
computer science department.
There was a little
bit of buzz about it,
apparently the chair
of my department
had talked it up
a little bit, so I
decided to investigate
a little bit.
It ended up being a
great way for students
to get involved into open
source, who may not normally
either have the ability
or have the time.
And Google Summer
of Code, I think
provides the opportunity
to really prioritize
getting involved like
that, so I happened
to pick a couple of
projects and went with it.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: What was
the application process like?
DREW RODMAN: So the
particular application
I chose-- I'll speak more to
my most recent organization
--but the project I chose was
called Melange, which provides
a platform for running
open source contribution
workflows, mainly Google Summer
of Code and Google Code It.
The way I happened
to pick that project,
I was just looking through-- it
could be a little overwhelming
for students who have never
participated in an open source
organization
before, particularly
when you have all these
topics and orgs and what not.
So I picked-- I was looking for
keywords, things like Python,
Django Web Development, things
I'm familiar with-- which
I recommend you do if
you're looking to apply
--and ended up selecting Melange
and coming up with a project.
And through the span
of a couple of weeks
or so communicated
with the organization
and potential mentors and
built up requirements,
and the project picked itself.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: Tell us
about the particular work
that you did on this project.
What did you build?
DREW RODMAN: So the
template for the project
itself revolved around the
existing system for connecting
organizations with mentors and
organization administrators.
So the existing system had--
you know, it worked, but it
had a couple of flaws
and flexibility problems
that we were looking to address.
So my initial project was to
go and fix all those problems
and come up with a
more reliable system.
What I ended up doing-- which
is a good example of evolving
requirements --but
what I ended up doing
was actually rebuilding
that entire system
to produce a more robust and
flexible work flow for that.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: That
sounds like a lot of work.
Tell us about how
you did it, and what
was your average day
like over the summer?
DREW RODMAN: So was a project,
and I got myself into a little
bit of a trap where I was
actually working part time
as well as participating in a
Google Summer of Code program,
which I will warn you is
a little bit difficult,
but is doable .
So on a normal contribution
day, or something like that,
I would usually have a current
task or design or something
like that that I was working on.
So I would sit down with
my designs for the day,
plan out what I
wanted to do, or what
I wanted to have
accomplished, have
as close to a constant
stream of communication
to the mentors and other
contributors to the program
as I could, and just
try to code through
and design and ask questions
and all that kind of stuff
throughout the day.
NATHANIEL MANISTA:
So you mentioned
speaking to your mentors.
How many mentors did
you have, and how large
was the organization,
and how much did you
communicate with them through
the course of your project?
DREW RODMAN: So initially
the projects technically
had one mentor.
Really, I had two
that I more or less
communicated with
pretty consistently.
When I first joined the project,
it was actually rather small
and has since kind
of grown, so I
got used to having new members
on throughout the summer.
In terms of the
actual communication,
we had several ways that we
would actually keep in touch.
You have the requisite blog
posts for students every week,
which is a great way
to keep you on task.
It's easier than you
think it is with updating
everybody and things like that.
We also had weekly Hangouts,
so we would all get together
and discuss what we'd been
working on through the week,
address any issues and
questions and things like that.
We also have an incredibly
active mailing list
and are always pretty much
on Google Chat or IRC,
and so I had a pretty easy way
to get in touch with everyone
if I needed to ask something.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: How
did your work finish
and what happened to you after
the conclusion of the summer?
DREW RODMAN: So my project
requirements did rather kind of
evolve throughout the summer, it
step me back a couple of times.
However, I was able to--
with the help of my mentors
and everyone --stay
on task and get
an almost perfectly--
or not perfectly,
almost full implementation
of the project
by the end of the summer.
It was not complete at
the time, so I actually
stayed on with the organization,
and I'm still working with them
in order to get that
project deployed.
But we did get it up and
playing at a couple months or so
after the conclusion of
Google Summer of Code.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: OK,
we've covered everything
that I wanted to ask.
Do you have anything
you'd like to volunteer
for potential students and those
curious about summer of code?
DREW RODMAN: Sure.
Sort of as I mentioned,
communication
is really, really important.
That can virtually
make or break you.
If you are in
constant communication
with your mentors, they
always know where you are,
you know what they
expect from them.
That can really kind of
ease the process for you.
It also helps you
lay out requirements,
which is very important at
the beginning of the program,
as I kind of experienced,
since my project did
evolve rather drastically.
My final kind of
little bit of advice
is come up with-- even
if you don't share it
with anyone, which
probably you will.
Even If you don't
share it, come up
with a plan or a timeline of
things that you want to do.
It makes the whole
process way easier
to manage, particularly if
you have other commitments
throughout the summer.
NATHANIEL MANISTA:
All right, thank you.
Thank you for your time and
thank you for joining us.
DREW RODMAN: Thank
you for having me.
NATHANIEL MANISTA:
All right, take care.
DREW RODMAN: You too.
NATHANIEL MANISTA: Bye.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm Nathaniel Manista,
and we look forward
to your applications for
Google Summer of Code.